we're going to begin with the news and
what could be a very big step in our
ongoing National Reckoning with what was
a threat to American democracy after the
2020 election and to that end the house
committee on January 6 has recommended
criminal charges against former
president Donald Trump and several
others close to him we saw the final
public hearing of the committee just
yesterday after an 18-month
investigation but there could still be
more Revelations to come we're waiting
on a report Wednesday Scott McFarland is
on Capitol Hill for us following all of
it Scott good morning
Tony good morning to you this is a final
flurry of activity in an unprecedented
investigation not only did the panel
recommend criminal charges against a
former U.S president they're set to
release their final report and
transcripts of key witness interviews
including inside Trump's Inner Circle
those in favor say aye aye an 18-month
investigation into the deadly attack on
the U.S Capitol ended with a unanimous
recommendation former president Donald
Trump be prosecuted by the justice
department ours is not a system of
justice where foot soldiers go to jail
and the masterminds and ringleaders get
a free pass the panel recommended the
justice department investigate the
former president for possible
prosecution on four charges obstruction
of an official proceeding conspiracy to
defraud the United States conspiracy to
make a false statement and acting to
incite assist or Aid or comfort and
Insurrection new interviews were also
presented by the committee including
with former Trump advisor hope Hicks who
said she tried to get the former
president to stop Fanning the Flames he
said something along the lines of
[Music]
um
you know nobody will care about my
legacy if
I lose the only thing that matters is
is winning in addition a 154-page
summary of the committee's investigation
was released painting a picture of trump
repeating claims about the election he
knew to be false summoning the crowd in
flaming and directing them to the
Capitol and interfering with the justice
department in his final days in office
no man who would behave that way at that
moment in time can ever serve in any
position of authority in our nation
again the committee also recommended
possible charges be brought against
California Attorney John Eastman for
allegedly advancing a plan to overturn
the 2020 election results which he
denies and the panel encouraged the
justice department to investigate and
charge others in the Trump Inner Circle
no one should get a pass
and I think the day we start giving
passes to presidents or former
presidents or people of power or
influences the day we can say that this
was the the beginning of the end of our
democracy the formal criminal referrals
are not binding on the justice
department but former Federal prosecutor
Joe Moreno says the mountain of evidence
compiled by the committee will be hard
to ignore the department though to its
credit will I have no doubt administer
Justice without fear or favor they will
say we look at the facts we look at the
law and we'll decide at the right time
if charges are appropriate the committee
is also recommended four of their house
Republican colleagues be investigated by
the house Ethics Committee for openly
defying the panel subpoenas that
includes house Republican leader Kevin
McCarthy who in two weeks will seek to
be the Speaker of the House
Donald Trump responded to all this
saying it was partisan and a kangaroo
court me
Scott thank you